we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine to david p let's take a
listen to this voicemail hey david i saw
a video with you on youtube and uh hey
treat male where I David is you know if
a feminist earlier wherever do you think
that uh too drunk yep amen hey do you
even lift bro and do you think that uh
lifting weights is something that
everyone should do you think that
everyone should have a standard of
exercise yeah I think lifting weights is
good I think it's not good to max out I
think it's good to be below your max
weight it seems it's not particularly
healthy to be maxing out your weight
lifting uh so yes I lift bro and I would
not advise you to call the show drunk it
seems like it people get really nervous
pad to get on and especially if you're
drunk all the sudden you don't know how
to talk but I do honor his resiliency
going after he messed up a couple times
on the bonus show today the u.s. high
school graduation rate has reached a new
record high we will also talk about a
group whose conscience is really putting
white evangelicals to shame I am talking
about Mormon voters we will have an
update on the 2017 david pakman show
calendar and also an update for you
about the fainting incident i will talk
about that on the bonus show there is
only one way to get instant access to
the bonus show it is by being a david
pakman show member you can sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership i
would love to speak to you on the bonus
show